Okay, listen gents, this episode is probably my favourite. I think it's
probably the most
valuable concept that I can give you in this mini episode. And I guess this is
ultimately
what makes this mini course the most valuable of anything in my personal
opinion. Although
everything else is extremely valuable, this on top is can be gold if it's
applied correctly.
And what I'm referring to is structural invalidation. So the reality is having
a structure OS is
incredibly, incredibly helpful and amazing. But as you evolve and grow as a
trader,
what you want to be looking to do is increase your own ability to read price,
plain and simple.
And there are some situations where even though the indicator will tell you the
structure is
bullish or the structure is bearish, you may want to look at reconsidering. And
there are
two scenarios in which that really happens for me. And that is when Asia high
or low is a
swing point. And when the daily and weekly bias are both heavily aligned
against your idea,
and I'll give you some context on the second one. The first one is really
simple. Don't use
Asia low and Asia high as swing points, especially when they're in tight
compact ranges inside of
a price like. So two different areas, you know, you can be inside of a price
like. So if you look
at this, I see this as kind of one price like right from a low to a high and
this Asia is inside
the price like versus if we were to zoom out a little bit, right? If this was
Asia low down here,
that wouldn't be inside the price like that would be outside the price like it
's on the outside
of price. It's quite clear, obvious and simple, right? This for me would be
outside of the price
like, right? This would be inside the price like, right? Because this is really
a price like.
And so yeah, hopefully that makes sense, right? Outside of the price like kind
of really outside
of the price like these levels. Right? That's why this is Asia high right here.
This level here
is Asia high, but it's outside doesn't get taken. So what it's inside the price
like, and it's your
swing point. It's a dangerous game. And it's something that I've learned
through a lot of
experience and a lot of data collection. If I'm in this scenario right now, I'm
looking at price,
what where are we? We have we were bearish, right? Break of structure bearish,
break of structure
bearish, bullish change of character, pullback bullish, break of structure. So
the 15 minute is
indeed bullish right now we're on the expansion phase. So the 15 minute is
bullish and the swing
lowers down here. This for me is where things get tricky because right now I
would definitely not
be trying to buy at this level. That's the first thing. I would not want him to
be buying in the
market at this price because this is a massive red flag for me. And so on one
hand, I would want
to be avoiding it. And you can see right price comes into that level has a
reaction. Price comes
into the level has a reaction. How many traders that don't know this do you
think that this is
induced, right? We hit in a swing low. It's a swing low, right? We've hit a
bullish water block.
We've had a bullish reaction, right? They're going to try and buy this level.
Big, big mistake.
See it time time again, press will run through. Now what's going to happen is
well, now the 15
minute is bearish. So now what people might be thinking is, hold on a minute,
let me, you know,
maybe sell this price level. But the problem is, is we're selling based off of
the idea
that this is a good low to use as a measuring tool. And it's not. So for me,
this is what I would
deem a quote unquote fake reversal, right? And it's always usually always the
change of character.
So for example, if you look at price, right, when prices print in market
structure,
like so, you can get times where the market won't agree with your logic. That
is normal.
So you'll be looking at it as, okay, low, high, high, low, high, high, high,
low, high, low, low,
ah, bearish. Oh, wait, what? Higher, high. And in reality, how the market scene
price was low, high,
low, high, low, high. And this in here was invalid, which is exactly what this
is in here. And so
it's always the change of character, but doesn't mean obviously the change of
character is bad,
the change of character is amazing. It's the first sign of the reversal. But
when you combine a
change of character with an internal leg of Asian low or high as a swing point,
it's very
easy to be kind of swayed on the wrong side. And so you might have taken a loss
trying to be a
buyer here. And now you might be trying to be, you know, a seller of price,
right? Now you might
try to be a seller. And again, at that point as well, you might very well get,
you know, induced
into price. And you can see price doesn't take out the low, right, it holds the
previous low,
and then expands and takes out the high and continues, right? And then we
continued bullish
from that level. And so yeah, right, there's another perfect example. I've seen
this instance,
we do just continue training lower. But ultimately, you want to be cautious
when you have internal
Asia, any high or low, there's supposedly a swing point. And you're looking to
trade from it,
I will tell you through experience that it's probably not going to be the best
decision for
you, because you can see a lot of the times London sweeps Asia, sweeps the
other side of Asia,
London sweeps Asia, sweeps the other side of Asia. It's a very common mechanism
. So that would be my
first kind of invalidation logic is depending on the situation, depending on
the situation.
This is why I think data and experience is very important, this way, like I say
,
inside a prosperity school, I have, I don't know, like hundreds and hundreds,
probably in close to
1000 trades live executed at this point, like me recorded the video of, of the
trade playing out.
And through that, you get to see the experience of understanding which high's
hold,
which highs don't, but mainly the invalidation logic is first and foremost, the
the h model.
The second one actually comes from the trade I'm in today. So today, right now
I am actually in
short positions, which you probably already know, because I already said it a
couple of different
times in the other episodes. But as I've right now, I'm in shorts and so are,
you know, a decent
amount of the prosperity school students. And this was the first take profit.
And now we've
closed that take profit. And I'm ultimately holding some partials down to here.
I think the price
might be able to make its way down here. Now, why the invalidation logic in
this scenario,
because it's nothing to do with Asia, but it's everything to do with the
directional bias of price.
Right. So again, remember, I said it's always the change of characters, usually
. So there's a
couple different schools of thought here. Right. The first one is, if we look
at the weekly time
frame, right, and this is the data that we have that backs up this hypothesis.
When we get this,
when this, so this is the previous week's price action, we closed below the
previous previous
week's law. And so based off of that information, we already have the data, the
actual data over,
I don't know what this is, like 15 years of data that tells us that there is a
68% chance that we
will trade into this law, a 68% chance that we're going to trade into this law.
Right.
So that's the first thing. We have a very clear bearish expectation. In fact, a
68% chance likelihood.
And what happens as well, as someone who this is just pure data, right, as
someone who has
been in this market now for, you know, heading into my sixth year, I can tell
you that this is
pure mechanical data. There is also the art of understanding price. And then my
internal operating
system that sees certain scenarios that can better predict than even the data
could itself.
And so I, this for me, because of how everything's set up, a moment or too much
detail, but because
of how it's set up, I deem it as a more than 68% chance of hitting this law. I
'm more so in this,
in the region of 75 to 80% likelihood that this happens in the amount of times
I've seen this
exact model on a weekly. So that's the first thing, right? We're expecting
lower prices.
And then you come into the daily. And again, the daily is the same thing, right
? The previous day,
the previous day wicks above and closes inside. And so I knew today was going
to be a bearish day,
right? With a, again, at a minimum, a 67% chance from a data perspective of a
15 years,
but also meet understanding price. And so you add that on top again, you're
looking at more of a
67% plus likelihood of it playing out. And so I'm expecting lower prices. And
so very,
very strongly, I'm expecting that the weekly is on a trade lower and that today
at least was
going to trade lower. Now I, this is the best thing about, you know, partials
and trade
management and stuff like that is I've already piloted out my position. So I've
already won
by not trying to buy today and instead selling anything else that comes if we
do end up hitting
these lows, which again, I do think we could if we do end up hitting these lows
, then it's just
another win for me, right? And so if we now go into the 15 minute timeframe,
knowing, you know,
knowing what we know, we can see another thing as well is that this 15 minute
structure is so
huge, right? If you actually just zoom out of price and you look at things that
only
overcomplicate this too much, but look at how bearish price is, we have a retr
acement back
up into this old level and we start selling off this in here. Like I said, the
market sometimes,
when you price is going down, it's always the change of character. Remember
that when prices
coming down, sometimes your logic might not be the logic of the market.
Sometimes we think it's high,
low, low, high, low, low, low, high, low, low, lower, higher, high, our with
bullish. So we sell here,
we buy here with wrong and wrong. Okay, low, low. Okay, now we're back. When
actually the market
didn't see like that, the market seen it as high, low, high, right, low, retr
acement back into this
old range, and then continuation sell off. That's a very real occurrence. We've
just seen it before,
we've seen it again now and it's always a change of character. And again, that
doesn't mean the
change of character is incorrect. The change of character is extremely powerful
. That's not
what we're seeing here. If we go to let's say for example, a one hour timeframe
, which bear in mind,
this isn't something that I typically do. I'm just using it just to demonstrate
quite simply.
We can see the actual one hour timeframe is extremely bearish. All right, we
have the one hour time
frame that's aggressive sell off, pull back aggressive sell off, pull back and
aggressive sell off,
but no, take into consideration this. This is the big emphasis here. It's not
about the hourly time
frame that will confuse you. It's not about that. It's about the daily and
weekly bias. It's about
that there is a very high chance that this week trades lower and that today
trades lower. And because
of that, because it's so clear and obvious, this is a day where I can come into
the market.
The same as I did yesterday, right? In fact, this is one day ago. It is my
humble opinion that
looking for longs is a bad play. I will take New York today, right? In here 10
hours ago,
if you were on live yesterday, look at where you're sold off from. For me, I am
still highly
convinced of my short bias, regardless of M15 structure. So this is already
before I'd even
taken this trade. I was highly conviction on shorts and how price played out.
The sweep that I needed to see and now we're selling off. And you can see this
here,
looking for longs is a bad play. I'm saying this at this point in time, right?
Looking for longs
and expecting price to hold through to these swing highs, which is what the
model would be,
is a bad play. If you try to long in here, you're going to end up taking out
the best case in our
break, even. And that's because of this contextual understanding of the
directional bias. And like
I said, this probably the, if any video I could create, this would be the most
valuable.
Because yeah, it's just there will be times where you've missed great
opportunities because
you were fixed on the indicator. And again, by all means, I say this to a lot
of people. Like,
look, you are more than welcome to just follow and only follow market structure
. And I, with a
very high degree of likelihood, you will make money, right? Providing that you
're obviously
trading correctly and emotions are involved. If we're just looking purely from
a technical
perspective, you are going to have a lot of success with the indicator itself,
just by
playing out and following the bias of just the indicator itself. But if you
want to become an
advanced trader, and you know, over time, you want to be able to decipher.
Maybe I should avoid
looking for this today, and it avoids losses and things of that nature. The two
main ones are
going to be Asia highs and lows at swing points, especially when it's internal.
And by far,
strong directional bias conviction, when the both weekly and daily are heavily
against us.
Meaning we have 15 years of data that's saying that there's a good chance that
we're going to
trade into this low down here. Of course, I want to trade with that flow. And
that's why I'm trying
to do it. And so, yeah, that would really be my logic for invalidation of
structure.
Don't be wrong, and I upset at the time I'm following my structure, but that 10
%
are able to make money by understanding context. Hopefully you enjoyed that one
.